Superman 64 widely regarded as one of
the worst games ever made and for good
reason this is a broken unfinished game
I remember renting this game from
blockbuster in 1999 sitting there
thinking why is this so hard why can I
fly through the ground why am i stuck in
the corner man I never played a game so
hard I was too young to realize the game
was literally not finished and to this
day it haunts my dreams so why do I have
it
well I'm a completionist I enjoy
collecting intento sixty-four
memorabilia and I saw it for an
incredibly cheap price so now we have
Superman 64 and I thought what could
possibly be more fun than trying to beat
this game and doing it on camera and
having my wife provide commentary along
with me let's do it I got my game
capture card set up and I'm about to
start playing one of the worst video
games ever made then there's no time to
waste so Superman 64 I remember playing
it for the very first time at the
different blockbuster will be sealed and
I remember seeing this going what's this
game about you know you will never find
your friends in this virtual world so
apparently the plot of the game is
essentially Lex Luthor made a virtual
world where Superman has to save his
friends and it's not actually metropolis
it's a virtual world all Superman gets
to do in this virtual world is fly
through a horrendous amount of rings and
you got me as to why tightest software I
thought this would be a good idea but
someone somewhere did and so now we have
Superman 64 and this game is not
finished I mean just look at the
beautiful green haze that surrounds
everything I mean essentially and look
how many rink it's actually really hard
to control Superman I mean it's absurd
and the game also does not explain
anything to you
you're instantaneously in it in a game
in which you're just oh I guess I could
fly through rings I don't get to be
Superman I just have to fly through
rings like then that's it the idea of a
virtual world basically means that the
developers don't actually
to try to create a real metropolis they
just have to make a little tiny world
man here we get to our first challenge
lift the two cars before they crush okay
okay I'm going
I don't know it just happened what's
happening okay
go throw it get it yeah it's gonna run
into that lady go they just tossed car
did I do it I did it I did it during a
time but doesn't really matter
oh my god I forgot how do I take off the
game doesn't tell you how to take off do
i do what do i do i remember is it a Z a
B wait I don't remember I have my
cousin's play this game here we go came
out I honestly don't remember what they
did to play it
do you remember watching your cousin's
play this I do I remember them cursing
in my aunt coming into the room going
like you're not supposed to say that I
bet they were like and the game sucks
and we spent money on this
I don't blame your cousin's my aunt was
kind of mad too so it was like the game
doesn't work now I genuinely remember
playing this as a kid thinking that it
was like really hard for some reason
like I didn't I was too young it was 99
yeah so I was like 11 I was too young to
realize that the developers who made
this game did not finish the game and so
much of it is just not done the worst
part of this is is that when you have a
game and your main character is Superman
there's so much fun that you could
potentially have go as we found out oh
I'm stuck I'm literally stuck right now
I can't move okay there we go
here we go okay I got 9 seconds left can
I do it no more cousins great two lines
so get used to Lex going I wonder what a
professional gamer
this game like the people who actually
you mean like the testers and stuff yeah
yeah I'm sure they were probably like
well crap okay coming to another
challenge put the police car at the end
of this road why in the living hell
would I put a police car at the end of
the road
Lex wins what happened just now what
happened I don't know do you see half a
Superman just disappears though like
like then there's no oh I get to do it
again
what a great fucking game nothing
happened
put the police car at the end of this
road okay here I go oh I blew up I guess
I guess it's just over and done and I
get to fly through some more damn rings
like to beat it you have to have a cheat
code or something there's a cheat code
this I think can you please look up
right now if there's a cheat code for a
level select so I can skip this damn
ring section I'm stuck again I'm stuck
again which means you get to go to the
roof okay there we go I'm out of it
hey level slot first begin a one player
game playing joining it to the option to
stay at the game on the controller pack
after saving place at the cave select
the load game option from the main menu
and choose the save game a prompt to
insert a rumble pack will appear oh whoa
hold the LP buttons for approximately a
second then press an a but even the
cheat code is stupids free will appear
that allows it any mission
alright let's try this damn thing again
here I go oh my god there okay so I have
to carry the police car and they're
shooting rockets at me and had to take
it to the end of the road because
they're shooting Rockets at the police
car let's see if I can somehow I did it
and I guess what I get to do now more
rings more freakin rings I have a minute
now that is what's known as collision
detection
this game has none destroy the four Dark
Shadows I'll try first I have to land
first year to build a move okay here we
go I'm trying okay I'm really trying
right now yeah good to go I got 30
seconds go what's happening I don't know
God did it
holy crap that was amazing okay let's
try to get to these damn rings so we can
get to an actual mission level okay I
can hear the thing the end thing I got 9
seconds oh shit here we go what's neck
use your super breath to blow the turtle
of three tornadoes away I'll try okay
now I have super breath let's how do I
do super breath who fucking knows oh I
think it's one of the C buttons there we
go which is it it's C up I think some
something's happening okay now I'm
underwater underwater
let's go Superman come on come on Supes
you got this
wait why did Lex win there was no timer
there's no time to waste
oh there's time to waste Superman okay
now I'm time I am apparently timed oh I
missed the thing
little super breaths oh my god you can't
actually there we go
they okay now apparently I'm time to
despite no literally no time see ya come
on see yet
well I have to like I have to stop I
have to stop flying psychic tornado by
the way I think I just got one of them
I'm really trying guys I'm really effing
trying right now in a real world in all
honesty why in the living hell with
Luther put out some tornado Superman put
them out with your super breath Superman
um please tell me this is it I did it if
you want to save your friends solve my
mase oh boy look what I get to do I was
alive when this this game was made guys
I was I saw it happen I can't even get
the ring I can't do it guys I'm gonna
try again
here we go go Superman go come on there
we go
I did it okay ask any gamer what their
least favorite two words are and they
will all say Lex wins ah excellent
where's Superman wins
yay I'm in a world now look there's like
some hmm yeah mmm Superman this was
being doing I am Superman
pinch mm yes all right now let's
actually try to play you know it's funny
I'm trying to press a and nothing good
up Superman oh yes
oh look at that look at Superman on this
box oh the box blew up in my face this
is the access code to the canal use your
computer to open it alright
Superman has his lucky computer in
somewhere I'll say this the music's okay
it's about it I wonder how I even played
this as an 11 year old I have a feeling
when I was 11 and I rented it from
Blockbuster from like from like 6 bucks
or something that I was just like I need
to get my money's worth this has to be a
tie I need to play it in your allowance
on exactly I spent my allowance on this
damn thing hey you know what I got the
same week you got this for my birthday
what's that
I got rollercoaster tycoon a
considerably better game in virtually
every way honestly this is this game is
amazing this game is emit a computer ok
please tell me that pressing B works oh
my god it worked
come on Superman very calmly strut to
the door don't use your SuperSpeed at
all just very calmly strut to the door
of course there's a way for Superman to
use his powers but you have to collect
power-ups for that because why would you
make a game where Superman just gets his
powers from the start I guess now there
I'm really about to die literally that
is the end of Superman no Superman can
honestly be killed by these robot things
that fire bullets which is hilarious to
me who the hell are you
you're too late Superman you'll never
stop the bombs without the help of the
dam workers and I've hidden them in a
secret cage deep underwater ok he
drowned the damn word if you smash the
door with your super strength they'll
drown give up in less than an hour
metropolis will be underwater I thought
this was a virtual metropolis
what oh there's a thing you swim go
rescue the people trapped underwater I
don't know what to do she just came in
okay oh you die
the propolis is crizzley underwater oh
yeah you're back to the thing
Superman was just killed by bullets from
robots and electricity from an electric
eel floating in a sewer in a virtual
metropolis that apparently is fake and
now I'm right back at the beginning
again I can't take any more of this I'm
not gonna try to beat the rest I really
can't
can you blame me I'm trying so hard
right now and honestly this game is
broken you can't beat it guys
that's that's it we're done guys I
really hope you enjoyed that because I
sure didn't
I'm kidding it was fun but not in the
way you'd expect it was like fun torture
guys I hope you enjoyed another episode
of retro rewind of having such a great
time doing these with you I hope you
guys look forward to next week because
we have another hilarious 'ti coming and
since we're talking about DC Comics and
how much some of their entries and
various things suck I thought I would do
a review of Superman for the quest for
peace with my friend the flick pick why
do I do this to myself guys thank you so
much as always for watching I greatly
appreciate it you guys are the best if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes